bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
c'est le coup d'envoi des jo d'hiver à
pékin le relais de la flamme olympique a
débuté au parc forestier plus de 1000
personnes vont se relayer pour porter la
torche à travers les lieux qui doivent
accueillir les compétitions cgo sont
marqués par la bulle sanitaire mis en
place par le régime chinois et par un
boycott diplomatique des états unis
suivie de sept autres pays pour
s'opposer à la répression contre la
minorité ouïghoure la france envoie sa
ministre des sports en pleine crise du
crédit à une vannière poutine est invité
d'honneur le président égyptien le
prince héritier saoudien mbs assisteront
également à la cérémonie d'ouverture qui
a lieu vendredi en pleine pandémie de
kobe 19 ces jo d'hiver de pékin seront
ils les plus fermés de l'histoire
l'enthousiasmé le triomphe des jo d'été
de pékin de 2008 ont-ils laissé la place
à une chine refermée sur elle-même entre
boycott diplomatique et tensions en
ukraine cgo sont ils aussi résolument
politique on va poser toutes ses
questions à mes invités j'ai plaisir à
revoir à mes côtés chen yan li bonsoir
sa rédactrice de fida consulting
également auteur de réussir sur le
marché chinois c'est chez eyrolles
également de cyrano confucius et moi et
ça c'est eux allés aux éditions de
l'archipel
antoine bondage bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et chargé de recherche
à la fondation pour la recherche
stratégique enseignant à sciences po
spécialiste de la politique étrangère
chinoise bienvenue également dans le
débat nous avons avec nous par skype
pascal boniface bonsoir directeur de
l'iris auteur de géopolitique du sport
aux éditions dunod bienvenue à vous
également
enfin eric monnin est avec nous
vice-président de l'université de
franche comté à l'olympisme membre du
conseil d'administration du cnoss du
cnof pardon comité national olympique et
sportif français auteur de chamonix à
beijing un siècle d'olympisme en hiver
c'est aux éditions des iris bonsoir à
vous est également bienvenue dans le
débat
avant de commencer cette discussion je
vous pose d'abord de faire un point en
images vous allez voir que les
participants à ces jo doivent se
soumettre à des contraintes très
strictes
derrière ses grilles sous haute
surveillance c'est la bulle olympique
des jeux de pékin une enclave de 60000
personnes en pleine ville
impossible ni pour les sportifs ni pour
les employés des jo d'en sortir les
autorités ont mis en place une boucle
fermée pour éviter toute transmission du
coc vide à la population locale dès leur
arrivée à l'aéroport les athlètes ont dû
se soumettre à des contrôles très
stricts
à la descente de l'avion nous nous
sommes directement retrouvé à
l'intérieur d'un bâtiment assez
spectaculaire et imposant avec beaucoup
de gens en combinaison de protection
partie
suite ça a été un processus assez long
pour traverser l'aéroport avec des
textes antiques au vide et tout ça
à l'intérieur de la bulle les mesures
sont draconiennes port du masque
obligatoire contrôle de température et
test pcr quotidien le personnel et en
combinaison intégrale
derrière une vitre de plexiglas à la
cantine les repas sont même servis par
des robots les sportifs seront conduits
sur les sites olympiques sans sortir de
la bulle dans des bus spéciaux des jeux
sous cloche auquel seuls quelques
spectateurs invités par les autorités
locales pourront assister
en toit du monde a sacré jos où kobe de
cette fois il faut quatre tests pcr
négatif pour participer est ce que son
ce sont les jo les plus fermés de
l'histoire alors évidemment des jo qui
sont dans une condition une situation
sanitaire sans précédent et on a même
une différence assez forte avec les jeux
olympiques d'été de tokyo on te rappelle
qu'il ya quelques mois pour l'objectif
l'objectif de pékin c'est de démontrer
que le pays est capable d'organiser ces
jo alors même que la situation sanitaire
est plus compliquée qu'elle ne l'était
au japon pour deux raisons premièrement
on est en hiver et évidemment lucia le
virus circule plus facilement
théoriquement et puis deuxièmement le
variant au micron est évidemment cra par
les autorités chinoises il ya eu
quelques cas des jeux font briller
quelques cas malgré sa politique zéro
vide effectivement mais l'objectif pour
les autorités c'est d'identifier les
coptes vite d'empêcher la propagation du
virus et c'est évidemment l'objectif
avec cette bulle sanitaires
autour des installations et d'ailleurs
des dizaines de personnes qui sont
arrivées à pékin pour les jo que ce soit
des athlètes mais surtout les équipes de
soutien ont été testées positives à leur
arrivée donc ces personnes là évidemment
au sortant entre guillemets du circuit
et sont mises en quarantaine génial mais
cessons on se souvient tout de même des
jeux des jo d'été de pékin en 2008 qui
avec 380 mille visiteurs étrangers à
pékin alors 2022 pas de public des géo à
huit clos c'est une sorte quoi de
symboles de la chine glacial
non je ne crois pas parce que c'est dans
un contexte très spécifique liée à la
pandémie de kobe de 19 et pour moi je
pense que même si les mesures semblent
très strictes aux yeux des occidentaux
finalement c'est bien pour la santé le
bien-être des athlètes parce que si la
chine faisait le contraire c'est à dire
que si les mesures n'étaient pas assez
strictes et s'il y avait des
contaminations
à la fin ce ne serait pas bien pour les
athlètes mais vont encore plus loin qu
effectivement que ce qui s'est passé au
japon ça va très très loin avec cette
bulle sanitaire oui moi je pense qu'à la
fin c'est vrai dans les intérêts de tout
le monde de ne pas avoir beaucoup de
contamination ou pas du tout de papas du
doubs de contamination et pour assurer
le bon déroulement des jeux olympiques
pascal boniface ce sont les géo les plus
fermés de l'histoire on a envie de dire
ça tout de même est-ce que c'est l'image
d'une chine fermé que projette
aujourd'hui la chine
il ya deux facteurs oui ce sont les
j'aurais pu faire une histoire puisque
effectivement que m'a dit encore le
bondage même au japon à tokyo il y avait
un peu plus d'ouverture et moins de
mesures d'isolement et ses jeux les plus
fermés s'explique par deux façons 1 par
la nature du système politique chinois
de par le cos vide 19 effectivement à la
saison hivernale oblige eux à des
mesures beaucoup plus strict en étaient
les chinois espérait pouvoir ouvrir les
jeux et faire la différence avec le
japon en disant au japon n'a pas pu
recevoir le mode le monde entier et
l'espoir et chinois était
un petit problème de liaison avec vous
pascal pascal boniface on va essayer
bien sûr de dire m ais dit eric monnin
côté sport il ya des nouveautés tout de
même cette nouvelle épreuve sportive
d'après ce que j'ai lu du ski freestyle
big air avec une compétition masculine
et féminine
la france a d'ailleurs deux grands
champions il ya 88 sportif français
sélectionnés donc malgré toutes ces
contraintes il va y avoir des géo
oui il va y avoir des jeux olympiques
mais simplement je fais revenir quand
même brièvement un petit peu sur
l'histoire de ces jeux cirque eux on ad
ce sont des jeux olympiques d'hiver tout
à l'heure on sait le comparatif avec les
jeux olympiques les jeux de l'olympiade
de tokyo c'est pas du tout on peut pas
du tout les comparer où on parle et à la
du relais de la torche avec 1000
personnes pour la porter à tokyo selon
nous étions à dix mille les jeux
olympiques de tokyo s'était deux cent
six nations je vous rappelle la queue
vendredi nous aurons 92 nation a qui
vont participer 2895 athlètes donc en
fait ce sont des jeux
généralement dans le milieu de la piste
l'avion on appelle ça ces jeux des jeux
familiaux sont pas des jeux temps aussi
important que tokyo faut bien rappeler
quand même sont des jeux familiaux 92
nations 2008 195 athlètes effectivement
avec cette nouvelle nouvelle épreuve
mais ne comparons pas du tout à tokyo
c'est pas du tout sembla pas du tout en
toi de mon avis a tout de même une
différence c'est vrai une différence
entre les jeux d'hiver et d'été il ya
une différence d'époque on sait on a la
pression tout de même que en 2008 même
si c'était les jo d'été il y avait une
chine un peu différente qui projetait
peut-être plus de libéralisme certains
par les mêmes d'ailleurs d'une
démocratie démocratisation -possible de
la chine ont l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
en 2022 on est quand même sur une chine
beaucoup plus repliée sur elle même
est-ce que vous avez cette impression
également parler de renaissance à
l'époque je pense que delà du point de
vue de nombreux occidentaux c'est la fin
des illusions oui effectivement la
période de libéralisation plus que de
démocratisation qu'elles soient
économiques ou politiques en chine qui
avaient été amorcées notamment dans les
années 2000 aujourd'hui est terminée et
la dynamique elle est inverse depuis une
dizaine d'années l'arrivée au pouvoir de
saisine pied et puis surtout le message
que vous voyez la chine est assez
différent en 2008 c'était l'arrivée de
la chine le retour de la chine dans les
grandes puissances l'affirmation de la
puissance chinoise
aujourd'hui c'est des jeux de la
consolidation la puissance avec un
message qui n'est pas tant un message
pour les occidentaux aujourd'hui qu' un
message avant tout pour la population
chinoise et puis dans un second temps
pour les pays qui participeront
notamment à cette cérémonie d'ouverture
et notamment les pays en développement
et des proches partenaires mes voyages
gazière projeté veut être faire passer à
sa population population si elle avant
tout le message de l'efficacité la chine
est capable d'organiser
ces jeux dans des bonnes conditions et
ce même si les conditions sanitaires
sont compliqués que les protocoles sont
extrêmement strict mais je pense que
l'ensemble de la population chinoise les
comprend et soutient ces protocoles qui
est très importante son père pierre
destrem ne pas y participer parce qu a
pas de public du tout tout de même en
chine on utilise beaucoup
l'internet et les réseaux sociaux dont
il ya pas le problème on va fêter ça en
ligne donc il garde tout son ligne ce
qui va se passer je pense que les
chinois attache beaucoup d'importance je
vous attire beaucoup l'attention du
public chinois ces jeux olympiques en
chine donc on va sur tout cela en ligne
donc le fait d'un public ne soit pas ne
sont pas physiquement présent ne
représente pas une frustration qui je
n'y pense pas vraiment ouais alors point
commun tout de même avec 2008 d'après ce
que j'ai vu c'est que vendredi donc 13
heures lorsqu'il y aura cette cérémonie
d'ouverture et bien c'est le cinéaste
jean mimi le réalisateur de d'épouser
concubine qui fera une nouvelle fois aux
commandes des festivités qu'est ce
quelle image et vous projetez génial ni
l'image de ces jeux
jour de cette ouverture avec ce
réalisateur justement il a très bien
dirigé en fait l'organisation de la
cérémonie d'ouverture des jo de 2008
donc les chinois lui fais confiance et
je pense que l'image qu'on veut passer
c'est ça correspond aussi à l'esprit
olympique ça veut dire que les gens de
différents pays et des diplômes
différents profils sert tous ensemble
pour des compétitions mais aussi pour
des échanges voilà pour refaire c'est
pour avoir plus de compréhension
mutuelle pour réduire les rivalités les
conflits voilà donc ça je pensais mais
sache que que la chine va passer depuis
pascal boniface cas pas une motivation
justement d'accueillir ces jeux dans la
rivalité finalement de la chine du japon
et de la corée du sud la corée du sud
avait accueilli les jo en 2018 les jo
d'hiver et les jo d'été également en
1988 la chine est ce qu'elle ne veut pas
égaler ce record
oui elle peut même le bac elle aurait
voulu donc ça n'a pas été possible je
pense qu'au début des chinois avaient le
secret espoir de faire mieux que les
jeux d'été du japon où le public
international n'a pas pu venir il y
avait très peu de spectateurs et au
départ il pensait pour que la crise du
commis 19 serait derrière nous et donc
faire la différence le japon ce qui est
important pour la chine ce n'est pas le
cas et je suis pas tout à fait certain
quand même qu'il n'y ait pas une
déception qu'il n'ait pas pu parce qu'il
soit pas possible d'accueillir le public
l'a bien sûr les gens se font une raison
du faible des raisons sanitaires
mais c'est quand même un regret puisque
quand on organise des jeux c'est quand
même pour pouvoir avoir des stades ou
des lieux sportifs rempli montré des
foules et faire participer le public à
la fois nationales et internationales à
ses jeux donc dans ce cas là il n'y a
pas de spectateur au départ les chinois
se disait brillera pas les spectateurs
internationaux milliards au moins des
spectateurs nationaux mais même ça ce
n'est pas possible et surtout surtout la
pression sur les sportives est très
forte les sportifs on a dix ans un
plaisir très modérée à participer à ces
jeux exigeront parce que ils se sont
préparés pendant quatre ans mais les
conditions draconiennes il ya la terreur
d'un thé carrie positif et de ne pas
pouvoir courir au jeu et le fait qu'il
n'y a pas deux villages olympiques ont
un vrai sens du terme donc il n'ya pas
de partage mais mature on a pu voir les
champions échanger entre eux avoir la
vue de locaux vides par exemple si faire
des séries avec d'autres sportifs la
nature a rien de tout ça donc ce sont
vraiment les jeux les plus fermés de
l'histoire eric monnin vous êtes
d'accord à ce que vient de dire pascal
boniface a fait beaucoup de pression sur
les sportifs
oui un non mais je suis absolument
d'accord c'est bien pascal boniface
simplement ce que je pourrais rajouter
c'est que pour la chine c'est aussi un
moyen de ces jeunes surtout bien pensé
ça aussi que c'est de s'attaquer à
l'industrie mondiale des sports d'hiver
et comme à pyongyang à grenoble 2018
nous avons eu une démonstration
notamment de nouvelles technologies je
vous rappelle qu'on a en 2008 sur le
site de pyongyang et quand nous on
essaie la 5g sont les premiers essais là
je crois que les chinois veulent
rappeler tout simplement bien qu'à
marcher ce marché ils sont bien présents
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée en 2017
il y à 8,15 millions chinois qui font du
sport d'hiver l'objectif sur nous pour
la chine c'est de conquérir un marché
d'environ 300 millions de chinois donc
je crois que au delà notamment peut-être
de l'absence du public qui est
effectivement on l'a bien noté qui est
une déception c'est sûr mais la chine
veut montrer qu'elle fait partie des
nations qui sont maintenant qu'il faut
il faut compter sur elles je rappellerai
quand même que la chine fait son entrée
notamment au cio le 7 avril 1979 donc
c'est relativement récent 1 par rapport
avec l'allemand la france 1994 où
d'autres nations et que globalement et
bien la chine en 2018 elle fait neuf
médailles il fallait a dit en fait 80
participants donc elle a
incontestablement
une histoire assez récente sur les
sports d'hiver donc je crois que la
préoccupation de la chine c'est de
montrer qu'elle existe
on le verra notamment à travers ses
trois occasions de beijing à la zone doc
et hanging et l'anah zones restant de
john ging qui tout simplement vont faire
la démonstration qu'il faut compter avec
eux maintenant sur la scène
internationale concernant les sports
d'hiver antoine jonas justement il ya
aussi cette vitrine technologique
d'après ce que j'ai lu en matière de
savoir faire sur les matériaux durables
la glace de l'anneau nationale de
patinage qui sera fabriqué à l'aide d'un
système de refroidissement respectueux
de l'environnement donc en fait ils
essayent de mettre en avant également
cela d'être respectueux de
l'environnement ce qui est d'ailleurs
pas prouvée mais pense que c'est
toujours le cas dans les jeux olympiques
qui rassemble à la fois une compétition
sportive est une sorte de foire
internationale ou d'expositions
internationales pour démontrer les
capacités technologiques du pays la
chine a beaucoup insisté surtout sur la
connexion avec des trains à grande
vitesse sur les transports qui serait
respectueux de l'environnement et
évidemment en europe beaucoup de
critiques sur le fait que la neige est
complètement et 100% artificielle la
réponse des autorités chinoises c'est de
dire que l'eau qui est utilisé vient de
barrages et de réservoirs artificiels
que ce n'est pas de l'eau qui est pompée
mais évidemment la question se pose
aujourd'hui et c'est le principal
problème
de ces jeux en tout cas une des
critiques c'est la question des droits
de l'homme la question des du respect de
l'environnement et est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui possible d'organiser des
jeux dans une telle condition en tout
cas à l'avenir et à ce qu'il ne faut pas
que le cio en tout cas lorsque les jeux
sont proposés dans un pays ne met pas
des garanties et des engagements
supplémentaires par exemple en matière
environnementale justement on va on va
reparler juste un mot génial et
justement pourquoi cette région d'après
ce que j'ai lu elle souffre déjà
effectivement d'une pénurie d'eau très
sévère quelle région mais la région qui
a été choisi pour les jets aux divers
moi moi je ne suis pas très sûr parce
que moi moi j'ai raté les derniers
chiffres je ne suis pas super à une
pénurie actuellement voulait dire tradi
l'avant tandis que les sites de
compétition sont alimentés par 100% par
de l'électricité verte mais que
justement il a fallu utiliser beaucoup
d'eau et caen pour justement au mettre
en place cette neige artificielle et que
c'est une région jeunes du manque d'eau
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il ya une pénurie
actuelle dans cette région c'est que je
sais c'est que dans ces régions depuis
des années la chine essayer d'améliorer
la situation par exemple on encore en
projet pour
transporter de l'eau du sud du pays vers
le nord et ça a amélioré la situation de
luisa sion d'eau à pékin par exemple et
en même temps que l'on parle de neige
artificielle
vous savez qu'en chine il ya des régions
du nord-est comme répit où il neige
beaucoup en hiver mais c'est très froid
là bas en janvier et il fait en moyenne
- 24 % est-ce que c'est idéal pour les
athlètes et je ne suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs vous savez que à pékin il ya
eu des anciens sites des jo de 2008 qui
seront réalisés
effectivement ils disent aussi qui
réutilise un certain nombre de sites lui
site des jo de 2008 qui ont été
réutilisées alors le contexte
international vous le savez évidemment
très tendu en pleine crise ukrainienne
et l'image marquante vendredi lors de
cette cérémonie d'ouverture ça sera bien
sûr celle de vladimir poutine aux côtés
de six jingping pascal boniface il y
aura même un sommet chine russie avant
la cérémonie d'ouverture de l'annuaire
poutine aux côtés de six jean ping est
ce qu'ils vont en profiter pour afficher
rapprochement contre les états unis oui
bien sûr c'est le but le fait de se
montrer ainsi et disons que poutine
aurait pu venir à pékin sans pour autant
faire un sommet avec jean ping il était
là lui héberger les jeux olympiques en
2014 donc il sait ce que c'est et qui
l'attend dans une troupe qui est normal
d'aller à son tour rendre hommage mais
bien sûr vu le contexte vu l'absence de
jo leinen et vue dre l'absence militante
de john dryden et de ses plus proches
alliés et vu disons le la position
française qui est en même temps en même
temps au boycott en même temps au
boycott pomme puisque on n'en voit pas
est les ministres les plus importants
mais on est quand même présent donc en
fait c'est effectivement une réponse
diplomatique de montrer que la chine
n'est pas isolé qui lie à un front
effectivement il ya un front anti
occidentales infondée occidentale et
c'est montrer l'unité le rapprochement
de la chine et de la russie qui n'est
pas nouveau ce mais qui se renforce au
fur à mesure que la russie d'un côté la
chine de l'autre sont de plus en plus
dans terme de rivalités de plus en plus
aiguë avec les occidentaux et cette
réalité de plus en plus être vues avec
les états unis fait qu'il y ait un
rapprochement je dirais mécanique entre
la chine et la russie dont les jeux
olympiques vont permettre un affichage
supplémentaire aux yeux du moment quand
on demande à des états unis boycott un
diplomatiquement il faut le redire cgo
sept autres pays comme le royaume uni
l'australie les pays-bas le danemark la
lituanie boycott également tous tous
donc pour protester contre le sort
réservé aux ouïghours et la reprise en
main de hong kong donc effectivement ça
sera plus politique que jamais alors
c'est évidemment politique la cérémonie
d'ouverture en elle même et comme l'a
rappelé parfaitement pascal boniface iv
position des pays qui boycottent et
qu'il assume des pays qui boycottent
mais ne l'assument pas vraiment des pays
qui sont représentés mais à très faible
niveau de représentation et puis des
pays qui assume à 100 % ces cas de la
russie sur ce point d'ailleurs le sommet
chine russie sera fondamental parce
qu'il devrait y avoir une déclaration
commune sino russe qui s'intègre dans
plusieurs déclarations qui ont été
réalisés et fait depuis la fin des
années 90 et cette déclaration sera
étudié avec beaucoup d'intérêt notamment
pour voir s'il y a une coordination sans
précédent sur les questions politiques
et militaires notamment par exemple en
lui avec l'ukraine où on a justement
est-ce que si jingjing soutien
véritablement vladimir poutine face à
l'ukraine
l'officiel éclair de la chine vis-à-vis
de la russie il ya évidemment un silence
chinois sur le sujet il est difficile
pour la chine de remettre en cause
l'intégrité territoriale d'un état les
questions de souveraineté par contre il
y à un silence qui de fait entre
guillemets est recherché par la russie
et puis il y sont communes manifestement
d'après ce qu'a l'air de dire la chine
aujourd'hui et puis justement voilà où
on verra encore une fois cette
déclaration au vendredi matin le
ministre des affaires étrangères ou
angui lui même a eu des propos le 27
janvier qui était un peu ambigu sur le
soutient d'ailleurs da à la russie mais
ce qui est clair c'est que la chine au
minimum ne dira rien et au mieux
soutiendrait par exemple n'ont pas
militairement évidemment lors du non
dans le cas d'une intervention mais
soutiendraient par exemple la russie
s'il y avait des sanctions occidentales
et comme l'a rappelé pascal boniface
aura été la chine a très largement
profité de ces sanctions occidentales
depuis 2014 puisque cela a forcé la
russie a conduit la russie à se
rapprocher de la chine y compris sur le
plan économique signalez yahiaoui
effectivement ya ce boycott à ce que ce
boycott d'abord atteint l'image de la
chine ce boycott et à des tarifs tout
d'abord joué je veux dire que je pense
qu'il faut pas politiser à un événement
sportif international parce que les voix
qui les politiques
bien sûr mais mais mais je pense que les
géo sont d'abord une fête pour les
athlètes et pour le peuple il ne faut
pas que les géo devienne un outil des
politiciens pour satisfaire leurs
intérêts politiques alors aujourd'hui je
trouve ça dommage te parler du boycott
diplomatique en même temps on envoie des
inévitables chignole forcément pour ses
membres les politiciens américains ben
oui ils veulent créer un peu plus de
bruit dos nu à la chine mais à la fin
les athlètes américains sont quand même
d'aller en chine donc moi aujourd'hui à
compétition sportive c'est vraiment le
boycott il est diplomatique c'est à dire
qu'effectivement vous n'avez pas de
représentation du chef d'état ou de
gouvernement ou d'un ministre je vous
donne un exemple concret en 2008 moi
j'étais à pékin il ya eu le boycott des
géo la communauté chinoise et moi on se
sent des blessés on est allés manifester
à la place de république pourquoi ce
sont des blessés problème avec le
tiberium semble fou quand on se sent des
blessés parce que pendant des années les
chinois étaient très motivés très
passionné pour bien à préparer
l'organisation des jurés la volonté de
dieu dans roth ou wii l'année dernière
je dirais depuis un certain moment
laissez moi expliquer parce que je
pensais en amalgame est ce que les géo
c'est une fête aussi pour le peuple et
pour que les athlètes il faut pas
mélanger trop delmon politique parce que
c'est une occasion pour dialoguer pour
échanger pour faire des compétitions on
est content d'avoir cette occasion si on
enlève sa balle y aurait plus de
tensions et de 6 points ce qui
intéressant vous avez des images
l'ajustement de la flamme olympique ce
qui est très intéressant c'est le choix
justement des personnes qui ont porté la
flamme aujourd'hui à pékin a deux qui a
été mis vraiment en avant dans les
médias d'état chinoise c'est un
militaire qui commandait les forces à la
frontière sino-indienne et qui à l'été
2020 a été un des commandants du côté
chinois de l'incident frontalier entre
la chine et l'inde qui a fait quatre
morts côté chinois plus côté indien et
donc a été la politisation faux est très
claire elle est de tous les côtés y
compris du côté de la chine eric monde a
invoqué attentats je vous fait réagir
mais eric monnin qui est justement
membre du conseil d'administration du
comité national olympique
est-ce que ce mélange entre la politique
et le sport c'est à chaque fois pour
chaque géo et là je dirais qu'il est
particulièrement accentuée ou pas oh non
pas du tout il n'est pas du tout
accentué non et puis j'ai eu en fait le
sport
les structures sportives font partie de
ce qu'on appelle soft power celles qui
sont utilisées comme 2 sooty simplement
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est que on
est des boycotts beaucoup plus dur
notamment je pense au juste à l'habiter
1956 à melbourne je pense 80 moscou 84
los angeles où nous avions de t'avoir à
moscou nous avons plus de 60 nations qui
avait boycotté la je crois qu'en fait
c'est une véritable chance pour les
athlètes moi je pense à eux je pense que
je connais beaucoup d'athlètes qui ont
fait les jeux qui est certain qu'ils
n'ont pas pu faire les jeux c'est une
chance que les états globalement qui
sont en désaccord les américains les
anglais les australiens et d'autre et
bien pause pour une fois aux athlètes
eux et ne pas les mêler à ces histoire
géo politique diplomatique parce qu'un
athlète ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que ça fait quatre ans qu'ils
s'entraînent pour les jeux et à chaque
fois c'est un pur espèce de fusible
notamment je pense 180 moscou 84 songe à
l'aise 56 à melbourne et bien qu on les
utilisait pour soi-disant régler ou
simplement montré un désaccord
diplomatique pour une fois eh bien ce
sont les diplomates qui centre shell qui
comment dire qu'ils se déchirent entre
eux les jeudis raid c'est une bonne
chose pour les athlètes olympiques qui
ont moins vont faire leur jeu et vont
défendre leur chance pour obtenir un
titre olympique pascal boniface voulait
réagir justement est ce qu'il n'ya plus
de politique peut-être dans ces géo que
dans d'autres il ya ce que toute façon
ça n'est pas inévitable qui est de la
politique dans ces régions évidemment si
la chine a candidaté pour héberger les
jeux olympiques aussi bien d'été que
divers mais pareil si la france a
candidaté pour héberger les jeux de 2024
c'est pour le prestige c'est pour
effectivement briller aux yeux du monde
entier tous les pays quelques sco nature
de leur régime il s'agit de régimes
autoritaires l'origine des maux drac
essaye d'utiliser le sport à des fins
géopolitiques pour brandir l'étendard
national pour montrer ses réussites aux
yeux du monde entier et par rapport à ce
qu'elle irrite mona effectivement je
suis entièrement d'accord et puis
pendant très longtemps le sport est un
peu la variable d'ajustement des
relations entre pays les états qui
s'entendait pas de gel 28 ans va
boycotter le sport mais ont conservé des
relations économiques culturelles
diplomatique et donc au moins on arrêter
avec ça et les sportifs n'ont pas à
faire les frais que de cela mais par
contre le le boycott diplomatique et
bien et là c'est effectivement un signal
politique et on ne peut pas dire qu'il
n'y a rien de politique dans les jeux
olympiques ils sont entièrement
politique mais le fait que les à pied
puis ce qu'on pourrait appeler de france
ira plus de boycott sportif j'ai par
exemple la corée du nord n'a pas
participé au jeu en corée du sud et là
ils n'ont pas le droit de venir en chine
le cio les a sanctionnés l'angleterre
avait dit quoi pardonnez moi parce
qu'elle vous êtes pourquoi être si la
corée du nord at-elle été sanctionné
parce qu'elle a boycotté donc on leur a
dit vous avez boycotter une année l'an
prochain vous n'avez pas droit de venir
comme ça vous réfléchirez à deux fois
avant de venir la prochaine fois lors il
est plus difficile d'exclure les états
unis que la corée du nord des jeux
olympiques mais l'angleterre avait dit
avant la coupe du monde 2018 en russie
dans legends sommes toujours dans ses
déclarations campés tueuse avait dit on
va en risque de boycotter la coupe du
monde parce qu'on est avec skype allons
n'est pas la baraka a ici et là j ai dit
ok si vous boycotter la coupe du monde
vous serez exclue des prochaines coupes
du monde donc pour l'instant on ne va
pas mettre de côté il n'y aura plus je
crois de boycott sportive mais il peut y
avoir selon la proximité idéologique et
politique des états une plus grande
présence diplomatique lors des
différentes cérémonies c'est ça antoine
bond assez la présence diplomatique qui
peut changer c'est ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui quand les états
unis boycott diplomatiquement ça veut
pas dire qu'il n'y a pas de joueurs
américains en revanche il n'y a pas de
représenter un représentant diplomatique
et là c'était pour protester justement
contre le traitement des ouigours contre
la mainmise de la chine sur hong kong
donc on peut comprendre aussi que ces
pays-là ait voulu boycotter
diplomatiquement les géo en tout cas
c'est une façon pour ces pays d'exprimer
un mécontentement et surtout une
inquiétude face à la situation en chine
le cas des états unis est vraiment très
spécifiques aujourd'hui c'est le seul
pays au monde qui considèrent et qui
affirme qu'il y à un génocide qui a lieu
en chine dans la région du xinjiang les
autres pays ne le font pas les autres
pays parlent de violation systématique
des droits de l'homme etc comme le fait
la france et c'est seulement certains
parlements c'était notamment le cas de
l'assemblée nationale française il ya
quelques semaines qui ont adopté des
résolutions mentionnant le le terme même
de génocide du point de vue états unis
cela fait parfaitement sens en réalité
de boycotter diplomatiquement après la
position des autres pays est plus
compliquée par exemple la lituanie qui
est souvent présenté comme boycottant
elle estime qu'elle ne boycotte pas il
n'y aura pas de représentation mais la
lituanie officiellement n'appelle pas au
boycott et ne boycotte pas
officiellement les gens alors stéphanie
je me permets pas ce que je pense c'est
très important je pense que tout
pourquoi tu dois être basée sur étaient
des preuves alors le sujet du signe un
très compliqué il est difficile de la
beauté en peu de temps par contre j'ai
quelques questions à poser et je pense
que les téléspectateurs peuvent aussi se
poser la question première question
c'est que j'ai beaucoup discuté avec mes
compatriotes
y compris quelques personnes qui vivent
au xinjiang qui sont nés là-bas la prime
est question c'est pourquoi c'est que
moi et beaucoup de mes compatriotes ont
vécu ou entendu est très différent de ce
qui est raconté dans les médias
occidentaux mon succès n'dia première
question deuxièmement sans parler des
fêtes ou de la vérification de fait si
on parle de la proche pouvoir
aujourd'hui on n'entend que ceux qui se
plaignent succès tient on entend très
peu et très rarement ceux qui disent des
choses positives sur et cynthia et
pourquoi on ne parle pas de la
répression horrible parce que je parle
de ce sujet pourquoi on parle très peu
du contexte des orist et séparatistes au
soutien et à ensuite pourquoi
oui je sais mais bon je voudrais parler
des dd oui courroux du poète c'est la
raison pour laquelle en tout cas il ya
les boycotts sorbonne bonaz aurait un
discours totalement différent du vôtre
j'imagine bien se rappeler aussi que si
le côté parfois puisque les jeux de 1980
on était à l'époque mais côté par le
fils ou d'un nul peu sur la chine et un
certain nombre de jeux joués mardi ainsi
ses jeux comme une arme politique on
voit bien tout de même que c'est
impossible de vraiment de faire en sorte
que les jo soient indépendantes des
questions politiques pascal boniface
d'ailleurs pour en revenir aux jo de
pékin en 2008 c'était l'ombre du tibet
puisqu'elle en parlait il ya quelques
instants chine ligne sarkozy tout de
même nicolas sarkozy avait participé à
la cérémonie d'ouverture en souvient
mais on se souvient qu'en gala merkel
par exemple n'avait pas fait le voyage
alors que giorgio bush en avait profité
pour voir vladimir poutine ça c'était en
2008 et c'était en chine oui donc on
voit bien aussi on peut pas bien alors
même si je je je suis d'accord avec mme
rodas dessus il ya un durcissement ans
depuis 2008 du régime chinois mais
george bush était allée très
tranquillement assister aux jeux
olympiques en 2008 et la chine n'était
pas à l'époque une démocratie qui se
serait transformé en 2022 en dictature
dont on voit que au delà de l'argument
des droits de l'homme qui est réel je ne
dis pas qu'il ya un problème du rôle de
l'homme en chine mais on voit bien que
c'est à ce que mentaliser d'un point de
vue géopolitique par les états unis
parce que on peut me dire qu'il ya un
durcissement de la chine mais la chine
n'a pas changé de régime entre 2008 et
2010 22 en 2008 puis george bush va en
chine en 2020 de john dryden non
seulement n'y va pas mais proclame qu'il
n'y va pas et appelle ses alliés à faire
comme lui donc bien sûr on voit bien
qu'il ya un bras piaggio peu pratiquée
je pense honnêtement que les dirigeants
chinois ont fait une erreur en
réagissant très vivement à l'annoncé du
boycott puisqu'ils disent d'à côté il
faut pas mêler sport et politique et de
l'autre qui disent c'est scandaleux que
les américains que dans les cas ne
viennent pas et boycotté en montrant
leur colère à la non venue de joe biden
ils ont pu montrer que sereine et l'orge
et n'est déjà mais je pense qu'il aurait
été peut-être plus habiles de leurs
parts de montrer une certaine
indifférence à la non venue de joe boyd
mais sinon qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
la chine et réagissent en disant qu on
aime bien le discours de nature banane
pour beaucoup pour un côté les jo de
pékin n'en avaient pas relations
politiques c'est ce que voulait dire
justement pascal boniface quand on aura
juste un mot pour revenir sur ce que
disait signale ni sur les ouigours il ya
bien une répression chinoise de la
population ouïghoure dans le chine qui
ont eu à vérifier je pense qu'il faut
être très vite s'avérer tout cas la
position de nombreux pays qui s'appuie
sur des travaux sur des documents et des
sources principe non vérifiées première
en chine vérifier si les rapports des
ong considèrent qu'il ya des violations
systématiques après il ya un débat sur
est-ce que c'est des violations
systématiques est ce qu'on parle de
crimes contre l'humanité certains
utilisent le terme de génocide ça entre
guillemets c'est un débat qui doit être
entre guillemets fixé y compris par les
juristes internationaux mais cette
répression et documenté en fait augmenté
les justes on avancera un petit peu dans
le débat parce qu'il nous reste 5
minutes un petit mot eric monnin
justement sur l'attribution des jo est
ce que ça pourrait changer est ce que
les critères d'évaluation pourrait par
exemple inclure des critères
environnementaux comme justement elle a
soulevé antoine monde as des critères de
droits de l'homme de démocratie
je crois que si jal comme c'est de plus
en plus le cas et je voulais en écoutant
les différentes personnes qui
interviennent je voulais quand même
rappeler que le cio s'est trouvé de bon
en fait une espèce d'impasse saint cyr
que ces jeux olympiques notamment de
2022 initialement il y avait eu pays de
l'est du pays qui cause datait d'almaty
beijing cracovie lives au somme unique
saint maurice et stockholm et au fur à
mesure que les choses ont avancé en 2013
on a eu des référendums notamment à
saint maurice après à munich qui ont dit
ban on jette l'épongé après en 2014 on a
eu la pologne l'ukraine est en fait il
restera tout y rester tout trois villes
il restait tout simplement almaty
beijing et oslo et aussi aux gets les
bourgeons plus de villes donc pourquoi
il ya si difficile pourquoi est ce que
finalement on n'a pas envie tout de
suite d'accueillir les jo c'est parce
qu'on ne correspond pas aux critères non
mais je crois qu'en fait eu beaucoup
beaucoup de villes où l'image de
d'athènes avec ce fameux éléphants
blancs ou de rio avec des dépenses
incroyables le seyon lorsqu'arrive
thomass pas en 2013 il va donner une
nouvelle feuille de route à quoi p
l'agent d'un travail qui a été revu
dernièrement et que ce qu'on appelle la
jambe à 20,20 +5 ou tout simplement il
va dire maintenant halte là il faut
réduire les dépenses il faut mutualiser
il faut reprendre peut-être des choses
j'existe ans si ce qui m'a d'ailleurs
s'être fait à pékin avec notamment les
oiseaux le cube le cube d'eau a cadré
deux cubes de glace donc en fait il va
falloir revoir l'ensemble et par rapport
à votre question initiale qui était de
dire est ce que les choses changent oui
les choses changent on l'a lu notamment
mais avec les prochains jeux olympiques
qui ont été notamment
voté à savoir la ville de brisbane en
2032 a déjà c'est déjà donné pour 2030
deux sachant que le site d'aulnay sept
ans avant la réalisation d'une ville
donc en fait tout est en train d'être
revus tenta donne tout est en train de
repenser j'irai aujourd'hui cette
surenchère de certaines villes vous
savez on a célèbre économiste qui
s'appelle wladimir andreff parler de
valeurs moody a tellement ils voulaient
les jeux s'il peut des dépenses
dispendieuses et bien qu'aujourd'hui
tout cela s'arrête prend fin et c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit notamment sur
paris 2024 un ou tout simplement et bien
c'est ce budget et maîtriser au maximum
parce que c'est regarder à la loupe
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
totalement fini sinon la solution des
jeux s'est regardés à la loupe antoine
monde ah c'est vrai on lorsqu'on parle
des géo de paris mais enfin bon il peut
y avoir dépassements de budget aussi
j'imagine oui effectivement encore une
fois les jeux de paris veulent se
présenter je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose comme des jeux non seulement
qui sur les questions environnementales
et plus largement sur les questions
sociales sociétales de maîtrise de
budget a également sont exemplaires on
le verra mais plus largement dans
l'ensemble des compétitions sportives
c'est vrai qu'il ya une pression
désormais qui est importante non pas
tant et non pas seulement des
gouvernements mais aussi de la société
civile et ça c'est un facteur qui a
toujours existé mais qui je pense est
extrêmement important on l'avait vu par
exemple en novembre 2000 21 lorsqu'il a
vu cette mobilisation sur la sphère punk
choix et c'était la société civile
notamment aux états unis en europe qui
s'étaient mobilisés bien avant les
chancelleries cette sportive 1,7
tennisman justement qui est
pascal boniface justement pour en
revenir sur les géo est ce que
l'attribution pourrait changer ce que
par exemple les critères des droits de
l'homme et démocratie pourrait rentrer
dans les critères louis hiel qui décide
qui décident parce que qui jugera les
juges alors on peut dire que oui il ya
des pays qui sont des démocraties
d'autres qui ne sent pas mais la
frontière est parfois difficile ya des
béquilles sans démocratie qui on prône à
attribuer les jeux en 2012 à londres
deux ans après qu'ils aient lancé la
guerre contre l'irak qui a quand même
été une catastrophe et géopolitique donc
on pourrait dire que les pays qui ont
déclenché les guerres n'ont pas le droit
de recevoir les jeux olympiques donc
c'est vraiment de plus en plus ya ces
critères-là mais on ne sait pas le
disons que le mouvement sportif
il est comme le nu il est universel et
il n'est pas purement occidental il
n'est pas purement démocratique dont il
faut distinguer le mouvement sportif
veut aller partout et donc il ne juge
pas effectivement la catégorie politique
le régime politique il y avait peut-être
mais par contre on peut faire pression à
lille et les vielles le faire pression
sur la chine mais par exemple au qatar
du fait de l'action des ong
le qatar a dû un peu mieux traiter les
travailleurs immigrés qui ne le
faisaient avant d'avoir la coupe du
monde donc l'organisation d'une
compétition sportive peut être un levier
le problème c'est que la chine de par sa
masse est assez peu sensibles aux
pressions extérieures
je n'ai pas mangé ses enfants ce
vraiment vrai le point côté la coupe du
monde aurait autant de bruit avec le
qatar avec la chine ça fait toujours
d'une position à boycott mais
effectivement est-ce que ça aide les
parce que c'est efficace ou pas ça c'est
une question effectivement qu'on
pourrait poser
à écouter chaignat liste est pas c'est
pas très efficace cultivant sur la chine
est ce que il va y avoir des médailles
chinois c'est ça que souhaite la chine
j'imagine oui c'est ce que la chine cède
ce que les autres pays c'est tout aussi
je vais signer un point il faut pas voir
les jo de pékin comme l'opportunité pour
la chine de boxer propres intérêts
uniquement parce que c'est aussi pour
les autres pays tout comme les géo de
paris en 2024 donc moi je le vois comme
une opportunité
d'échangé une opportunité
'gagnant-gagnant' tout à l'heure on a
parlé du secteur du sport vous savez en
chine est le marché et grands y aura
beaucoup plus de gens qui pratiqueront
le ski tôt ce sport est donc j'encourage
les entreprises françaises ou
européennes à aller s'est développée
puisse en chine on te demande alors
c'est intéressant puisque c'est un des
slogans de ces jeux olympiques d'hiver
tsbv church et yeux et c'est intéressant
ce que cette expression a été elle est
extrêmement politique puisqu'elle est
mentionné notamment dans les dix
principes de la diplomatie selon la
pensée de jean ping et donc on voit que
même jeu dans le slogan et même dans les
chansons officiel évidemment des
références politiques donc que d'autres
pays puissent y gagner évidemment mais
comme la chine comme tout organisateur
de jeu évidemment il gagne également
pascal boniface est ce que tous les pays
on a gagné finalement à 2 cgo par delà
la politique classement des médailles
les jeux d'hiver c'est un peu
particulier parce qu'ils ne sont pas
universels pays africains il ya assez
peu de latino-américains il ya assez peu
de gens du proche-orient donc je
vraiment universel ce sont les jeux
d'été les jeux d'hiver sont encore
marquée par une domination occidentale
que la chine veut justement brisé en
montrant qu'elle peut aussi réussir en
ce domaine là mais pour l'instant disons
que le palmarès il est quand même très
occidentalisée eric monnin des chances
françaises même de ramener des médailles
ah oui totalement va écouter le principe
c'est d'essayer de battre cette neuvième
place à deux points de chang en 2018
avec ses tables 15 médailles donc je
pense que globalement on serait à peu
près sur cette logique là d'une
quinzaine de médailles avec cinq
médailles en or que dalle rigoler qu'on
avait récolté absents jambes j'aurais
simplement dire que pour la chine est
bien le record c'est 6 11 médailles ses
cinq titres qui avaient été obtenus en
2010 avant coureurs moi je crois voila
voila je crois que la chine
c'est son objectif c'était patience
médaille je crois que la france nous une
quinzaine de médailles 6 voilà on peut
compter sur ceux sur ce bel objectif là
dans le sang merci beaucoup eric monnin
merci beaucoup à vous pascal boniface
merci génial y d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous en soi une bonne base merci
à vous tous deux heures suivis et reste
avec nous sur france 24